check one two all right good morning
everyone uh I am so excited to be here
in Sydney uh I count this as a a real
honor and a privilege to to be here uh
as part of the NDC conference and as you
can tell I'm I'm from the states I'm
from the deep south of the states in a
in a uh the state of Georgia so I speak
fluent redneck I I hope you can
understand uh my my English my version
of
English my name is David Neil and you
can trust me because I have a beard and
I ride a motorcycle and I consume lots
of bacon and
caffeine and uh I've got my family here
with me we've had just a incredible time
uh for the past week we we came came in
a little bit early and um yeah Sydney
has been awesome I wish we could see
more of Australia except for these guys
I don't what is up with these little
Annoying Critters uh we tried to go see
the Sydney Opera house and we're just
attacked constantly by these by these
guys um so to start off I wanted to tell
you that JavaScript
has won the web uh SC youve you know you
just got through with Scott hanselman's
talk he may have even I wasn't in there
but he may have even said this phrase
he's talked about many times about
JavaScript being the the lingua to
Franco of the of the web it's it's you
know we all like to bash on JavaScript
right it's uh it's it's not the language
we would choose but it's the language we
deserve
um and Atwoods any application that can
be written in JavaScript will eventually
be written in JavaScript and if you just
search for JS Linux that's an entire
Linux operating system running in the
browser uh which is
insane and Douglas
crockford uh at a uh on a speaker panel
one at one conference said JavaScript Is
tragically important and if you remember
or if you know Douglas crockford is the
author of one of the most important
books in JavaScript JavaScript the good
Parts which is suspiciously smaller than
any other JavaScript book out on the
market so it's JavaScript the good parts
just very short
book so this talk is about node.js uh a
little bit from my perspective as a net
developer and we're going to talk about
why node.js why uh why should we even
consider using node.js as a as a
technology and a bit of of a crash
course some tools and Frameworks that I
have found that are are great to uh to
use with node and maybe some integration
strategies with some existing net
code and of course no JS over the last
few years is completely exploded unless
you've been under a rock you've you've
seen just a an incredible uptick and and
lots and lots of Buzz about nodejs it is
an amazing uh technology it it is
Javascript on the server so it's
JavaScript based it's you know it's
promises that you can focus on a single
language from from back end to front end
so if you if you are how how many
consider themselves web
developers yeah vast majority of you so
you know we already deal with JavaScript
on the front end uh JavaScript on the
back end is is a pretty interesting uh
premise no. JS is built on the Chrome V8
JavaScript engine and is very very fast
and efficient uh V8 as you know has been
in the past the fastest JavaScript
engine I don't know if they can make
that claim anymore uh Microsoft Shakra
has got some pretty impressive uh
benchmarks and you can even use Shakra
in with nodejs I think there's a shim
where you can uh swap out the JavaScript
engines but uh the V8 engine is is very
similar you might say that well
JavaScript is is dynamic it's um it's
it's not a compiled language well if you
think about it net is not necessarily A
compiled language either when you
compile net it's turned into inter IL
and it's only just in time compiled when
when it's executed in the same fashion
JavaScript when it's first uh executed
in node is also just in time compiled
and is uh running as machine codes so
it's just as fast and efficient uh at
runtime as
isnet now the interesting thing about
nodejs and the and the JavaScript engine
is that it's an asynchronous event Loop
so your code is um you kind of fall into
an asynchronous development pattern not
that you can't do async and a weight and
all those kind types of things with net
but the the kind of the patterns that
we've been uh presented and you know
that we've learned in over the years has
been a very synchronous pattern whereas
in node.js when you're looking at all
the code samples and you're using
callbacks and promises and those kinds
of things you're you're falling into an
asynchronous uh pattern and this a uh
single threaded event Loop it sounds
counterintuitive but because of the
contact switching and stuff that that
you don't have to deal with with
multi-threading it can actually be very
very efficient and and handle uh
concurrency really well
the no. JS Community has just exploded
um last time I checked there were over
250,000 modules available for node.js
compared to some somewhere around
60,000 um new get
packages uh the community has embraced
node.js because it is Javascript and
regardless of your background with your
php.net
Java um become if you're a web developer
you know JavaScript is a language that
that you know and it has attracted web
developers from all other platforms to
uh to to jump on board with
nodejs and it's been very very
successful and then Microsoft themselves
has been uh also involved with node.js
so they they're they were involved early
on with nodejs and making sure that node
can uh can run on the Windows platform
no. JS is a first class citizen in azure
um they make it really really easy to
deploy node.js applications in Azure and
the all the aure services have first
class node.js uh libraries that you can
use to to do things like uh message the
message bus and other types of services
that are
available and one thing I'd like to say
is that no JS JavaScript is not your you
know not your dad's JavaScript so we all
bash on on JavaScript being uh you know
this this language that we all love to
hate but uh in the in regards to nodejs
the latest version of node you can take
advantage of all the great features of
like es 2015 or
es6 um 6.3 of node.js is 95% es6 e or ES
2015 compliant so almost everything that
you can you know except for maybe uh
tail call uh optim optimizations is
available if you're building on node so
you can do things like you know the fat
Arrow syntax you can do uh spread
operators you can do uh all these great
new features that are in the es6
language and it is a uh awesome uh it's
a whole new world you know in in terms
of JavaScript that's really really
awesome so a little bit of background of
about me I've been a net developer since
the early days of net I was at the PD C
uh conference in 2000 when net was
announced they gave us uh they gave
every attendee this book called
presenting C and being the nerd that I
am I went back to the hotel room and I
read that that entire book and I knew
that I wanted to be a net developer that
this C language is really awesome so
I've been doing net and C for forever I
work for this company called linkit we
do conbine
software and our stack has been
traditionally Microsoft so it's MVC and
C we use SQL server and then hibernate
and we've got a whole spaghetti of of
JavaScript and jQuery type code and just
about every jQuery plugin on the planet
is embedded in our application at one
time or another um which has led to a
lot of really
uh you know as we've scaled and as we've
grown has has led to some you know
really
hard uh spaghetti code to to decipher
some really challenging problems with
with the just the Microsoft framework
and there's been a lot of frustration in
maintaining the application that that we
have and and to be honest the the stack
of technologies that we have we've even
you know started to run into scalability
issues uh not not that you know net
isn't capable of scaling but you know
just the choices that we've made over
the years the the the things that are
embedded in our system uh became really
really difficult for us to to scale and
so JavaScript for us is a strategically
important language since we are a SAS
product and we build a web application
JavaScript is really really important
and um it became clear to us that we
needed to be JavaScript
experts and no. JS seems to be um you
know just reinforces our our ability to
to build great web applications from a
recruiting standpoint node.js has been
awesome because you know the community
of JavaScript developers now instead of
uh in our Market where where my company
is based in uh in Nashville Tennessee
theet uh Community it's a large
community but there's so much Demand on
good talent in our community that it's
hard to get recruit uh you know really
good net developers but if we're using
node.js and are able to use JavaScript
then we can also pull in pretty much
anybody from any background any um uh
web-based uh technology so we have we
now have people who have come from Ruby
backgrounds from from java uh from PHP
and that's a good thing because they're
bringing in these you know this polyglot
experience you know all these IDE ideas
and Concepts these patterns uh libraries
and so forth that they have learned on
these other platforms and they're and
they helping us to be much better at
what we
do and we have found that in building uh
some of our services with no JS that it
just is just a much more productive
environment it's there's much much less
friction uh we do we're doing things
like test test first uh you know test
driven development
uh we're building microservices we're
able to take advantage of other
Technologies like rabbit mq and riok and
redus and the fact that it's
crossplatform and we can do things like
dockerize our applications and we can
deploy to Linux uh servers and and all
those kinds of advantages uh we have you
know our our devops guys really love uh
the fact that they can take our our our
Docker containers and vagrant and all
those other Technologies and be able to
easily deploy those things into
production so this has been more of the
reaction that a couple of years ago we
decided to run an experiment and and do
some projects with node.js
and um my team was one of the first
teams to do that and within a couple of
weeks of of into into this project we
were doing uh I I asked all the you know
the other developers well how do you
feel about nodejs so far and it was just
high fives everywhere it was
um we we're you know just loving the the
technology loving the the you know like
the less friction with building
applications and we you know we haven't
looked back now we still give our
developers the choice if they want to
build a net application you know they're
building a c a certain feature or
certain Service uh they can they have
the choice of building it in net or
nodejs but by far most of our developers
are building uh services in in node.js
there are a number of great articles out
on the web uh this one is why know JS is
becoming the go-to technology in the
Enterprise and this resonated with us as
well as any a lot of other companies
that I've talked to that have gone the
route of using node.js and it's rapid
Innovation delivery uh developer
happiness being able to attract and
retain Talent you know it's a it's a new
shiny thing you know sort of speak so
people are excited about working with
with nodejs and JavaScript is just you
know it's just a great skill to have
regardless uh of of being nodejs or not
and performance has just been amazing to
me no JS
exemplifies start with the simplest
solution that works and do one thing and
do it well node.js is is essentially a
JavaScript execution platform there
there's not a whole lot that's built
into node.js itself there's like some
file system capabilities some networking
capabilities but that's it the rest of
it is all mpm uh uh or modules that you
can pull in to to make node do whatever
you want it to
do some of the node.js you use cases
single page apps um API realtime
streaming all these are are great
examples uh proxy service we'll talk a
little bit more about that later as part
of an integration strategy stry but I
like to say that node.js is you know
it's anything you want to do that's
connected to the internet node.js is the
perfect uh solution for and in
particular node.js from the very
beginning for for years now has
supported things like real time
streaming and websockets and is really
really uh great at creating that those
modern you know push type experiences on
the web so if you're pushing data to
mobile apps or in real time type
applications on the web uh node.js is is
a great solution for
that and I'm happy to say that node.js
is is more than just backend you know
node.js has typically been uh just a
backend server for doing API and web
related things but there's a lot more
you can do with node than that there's
you can create automation scripts since
it is just a JavaScript ex execution you
can create you know lots of automation
things for like devops
you can create command line tools using
nexe um I've used this to create u a
number of utilities for for applications
and you can create desktop apps using
either node webkit or uh electron
electron is one of my favorite new
technologies and it's it's so awesome so
electron was built for uh adom by GitHub
and is the desktop shell uh that that a
number of applications have been created
on how many here use
slack well if you've used slack on the
desktop you've probably used an electron
application and then Visual Studio code
this was a a huge eye openening
experience for me when I saw Visual
Studio code I'm thinking well wow
Microsoft has figured out how to getnet
to to run on on on Mac and Linux and you
know create a desktop app well well they
didn't use net they use electron they
use node and and uh and chrome uh which
is what electron is built on if you want
to learn more about electron there's uh
I think maybe more than one talk here
this this week but I know there's a talk
tomorrow at 11:40 on uh writing desktop
applications using web Technologies and
if anyone's interested uh I'm actually
giving a uh talk on electron tomorrow
night at the Sydney node.js
Meetup there are quite a few case
studies of successful node.js
uh uh implementations or you know
migrations from from platforms to
node.js Fandango which is a ticket sales
for for like movie tickets in the states
um they have moved from net to node.js
and uh their experience was much like
ours drama atically shorter development
Cycles uh they're moving toward a
microservices architecture flexibility
and deployment all those things are are
just great U benefits of of moving to
node.js
PayPal is another great case study this
is a a company who ran an experiment uh
when they first started looking at
nodejs they're they're a Java uh based
you know traditionally but they're
looking at U at at no and they decided
to have one team create this new
application in Java and another team
create in node so that they can compare
you know the experiences between the two
and what they found was when they built
the node.js app they could they created
it two times faster with fewer
developers they had less code and fewer
files they had a a huge performance
improvement over the Java app and also
uh this great performance in in average
response time what I what's so
interesting to me about this particular
case study is that PayPal had been doing
Java for years and so the team who is
creating this Java application the Java
equivalent they they should be Java
experts and yet this team who had just
you know for the first time touched
touched node.js they were able to create
a a much better application uh just
right out of the gate and so you know
they've they've since switched to no. JS
completely
and uh have had great
success Walmart is another greata case
study Walmart is you know uh I'm sure
you you've probably heard of them
they're one of the biggest retailers uh
they ran their experiment on Black
Friday 2013 I don't know if you know
what Black Friday is but it's like the
the number one shopping day of the year
in the states it's the day after
Thanksgiving holiday and uh so many and
you know what better time to run an
experiment than you know your your
heaviest shopping day of the year but
they uh they switched their mobile
platform to using
nodejs and they had just an incredible
phenomenal results they had 200 million
um concurrent users and you know you
know they hard their their servers that
were running node.js hardly broke a
sweat and they also experimented with
deploying live updates during Black
Friday without any trouble
so who else is using node.js uh there
are lots and lots of of organizations
that that are using node.js today
um there uh if you if you search for um
a no. JS industry I think on noj s.org
you can see a a long list of of
companies and organizations that are now
using noj either primarily or as as a
major part of their
infrastructure as I mentioned devops is
is loving us as a you know internally
with with no JS because of its small
footprint and being crossplatform it's
very event driven so uh this this devops
movement in uh that we have in software
development there's already a number of
packages available for node that do all
the kinds of monitoring and uh events
that that devops is uh really interested
in seeing as part of the the health of
your application so it's there's a the
open source Community because it is so
popular there there just seems to be a a
a a huge number of tools and options
available to you to to help drive a
devops type of En of
environment now I don't know if you can
read this but it says this is a chart
from
uh another article what is node.js used
for the 2015 nodejs overview report
the the title of this chart is how long
have you worked with node.js and do you
like your job so over time it seems like
the more you work with node.js the
happier as a developer you are because
of the the less friction the the number
of tools that are available the packages
just the uh the whole the whole overall
experience is just a a great uh place to
be installing node.js is really really
easy
you can go to nodejs.org click a big uh
green download link and and run the
installer or how many here are familiar
with
chocolatey awesome good number of you
are uh I'm I'm surprised at uh how many
people are already familiar with
chocolatey but this is one of my
favorite tools on U you know you can see
that I'm running on a Mac but I have VMS
for Windows that I still maintain a lot
of net applications and and so forth so
each time I spin up a new windows VM I
use chocy to install a lot of U my
Baseline of of tools and so to install
chocolatey you just go to choc.org
there's like one thing that you need to
install to get it running and then from
the command line you can do things like
Choo install nodejs do
install and as I mentioned before when
you install nodejs it really is just an
execu a JavaScript execution
uh engine it's just node.js is not
anything fancy it is two command line
utilities basically one is node itself
which is you can type node space and
then some Javascript file to execute it
and the other is mpm mpm is the node
package manager it's it's kind of the
nougat equivalent this is how you use
mpm to install uh packages out of the
mpm
registry uh two dependencies you should
be aware of of uh with node.js
is uh node.js is crossplatform
compatible so you can run nodejs on
Windows on Mac on Linux and most of the
modules that you may use are are pure
JavaScript but there's also uh a chance
that some of the modules you use have C
libraries that need to be compiled on
the machine or on the architecture that
you're running on so in that case
there's two things you need uh you'll
need python version two some vers some
version of two python 2 and you'll need
some type of C compiler uh most recently
you can either if you don't already have
Visual Studio installed you can use uh
choo install Microsoft build tools or
you can install the the build tools uh
from um directly or you can download
visual studio Community 2015 and with
with that C++ compiler um you can have
you can you know build those native
extensions or those native modules for
node uh and if you're running uh node.js
or if you're running Visual Studio
already uh there are there's an open-
Source node.js tools that you can
install that give you uh some project
templates and some other things uh
minimum requirements are you need Visual
Studio 2012 Pro or one of the free
community Editions
uh you will need the latest versions of
Visual Studio
updates and or you can if you have uh
msdn subscription you have access to a
lot of uh Azure resources you can spin
up an Azure VM that already has uh
visual studio and the nodejs tools uh
already installed so that you can use
that as your sandbox to play around with
uh with node.js in visual
studio with that I'm going to show you
just a a brief U view of what those
node.js tools look like in Visual
Studio
well got to stop this
first all right so I have Visual Studio
open here and I know that's very small
I'll zoom in when I need to um so I'm
going to start a new
project and with the uh nodejs tools
installed you'll see that under
JavaScript there's a number of project
templates uh that are that are now
available under node.js and those that
can be from existing node.js code to
starter uh Express applications Express
is um arguably the most popular web
framework or starting point for building
web applications with node.js
and there's also a number of azure uh
applications that are available I'm just
going to choose the basic node.js
Express 4
application um all that's
fine is going off and creating the
application now um unfortunately I won't
be able to show you everything because
the the wireless here is a little bit on
the downside but um after this is
created I do want to show
you at least a couple of things about uh
creating an application in visual studio
so when this comes up we've got our
project and our appjs file which is kind
of like the bootstrap for for this
express application what node.js tools
for visual studio gives me is the
ability to set break points and gives
gives me a a uh great debugging
experience straight from visual studio
so I can fire this up uh in my browser I
would hit that break point and uh I can
I can inspect those variables I can set
uh watches I can uh look at the the call
stack all those things that you would
expect uh from as a net developer being
able to use uh you can also interact
with a JavaScript language as
well now
unfortunately when then um you can see
this over here all these things are
missing and that is because when you
install a nodejs application uh there's
this uh metadata stored in a in in this
file called package Json and right now
it's attempting to go out to the
internet and pull in those packages that
are are referenced just like nit
packages right so it's going and trying
to download those packages and make them
available to this this application
unfortunately it's not able to do that
but I can show show you that if you
right click on mpm there's uh this
install mpm
packages um dialogue that comes up and
very similar to
nougat it's all cached locally so I
updated it last night I can do things
like I can search for low
Dash and I can choose uh low Dash or
underscore those are popular uh
JavaScript framew works and I can
install those directly into my my uh
node.js application adding it to the
package Json by default that means it's
storing that met metadata as a as a
package and um so it's it's very much
like a a nougat type uh environment for
for installing node.js uh
packages
what I want to show you right now is
I've got this exact same project pretty
much in Visual Studio code so this is
actually running on my Mac not in the
windows VM but it looks identical so if
you bring up visual studio code on
Windows or Visual Studio code on Mac or
or Linux these These are exact same uis
and it's really really good so um I I
almost never use visual studio anymore
uh visual like Visual Studio 2015 unless
I'm actually working on a net
application that I need to maintain if
I'm doing any node.js development at all
I'm either using visual studio code or
something like Sublime Text um Visual
Studio code is is really really
refreshing it's it's fast um and it's
really powerful so just like Visual
Studio I can set break points anywhere
in the code and I can I can I've get
intellisense uh if you anybody here here
use
typescript so you got typescript
capabilities in Visual Studio code and
uh you can get intelligence to those
typescript
definitions and I can switch over here
to to debug and fire up this
application I can switch over to say
Firefox and say Local
Host 3000 and now I've just hit the
break point here on this this particular
route and I can I can Mouse over and see
inspect those variables I can see all
the properties and functions that are on
that variable I've got a call stack over
here on the left um I can set watch uh
points so a visual studio code and also
get like the step over and step step
into and all those kinds of things that
you would expect from a from a debugging
standpoint so it's really really
awesome
so we talked about Visual Studio code
Linux Mac and windows it's a considered
code assistant so it doesn't have the
full capabilities of of like Visual
Studio but it it is really really good
great environment for JavaScript I I've
continually been been impressed with
Visual Studio codes uh ability to um
create node.js projects and debug
JavaScript um so some Core Concepts
about nodejs that you should be aware of
mpm we talked about being a a a node
package manager so when you're creating
a new project from scratch if you're not
using like the project templates that
are in node uh the nodejs tools and
visual studio you're going to want to
create a project for your for your uh
for your application and start by by
using mpm andit and this is going to
step you through some questions to say
you know is this the name of your
project and it's going to create a
project. Json file at the end with with
uh some of your your information about
your project and then from there you
would use mpm to install packages um so
in this case I'm installing low Dash and
I'm using-- saave to save that
dependency in the package Json
file um when you're as I mentioned for
jav the JavaScript that you use in
node.js is a little bit different from
what you may be uh using on the front
end so some Core Concepts about node.js
is when you're uh requiring in use
node.js uses
commonjs uh for
dependencies and for for modular
JavaScript so require is kind of like
the Imports or using statement uh in
this case require with just the name of
the module is is how you would reference
uh built-in node.js modules in this case
I'm using the uh FS which is a file
system allows us to read and write files
in node.js
it also with the same kind of syntax we
can we can reference modules that have
been installed by mpm so require Express
would be how we would reference the
Express framework um for for node that
we used mpm install for and then if
you're creating your own modules you you
provide a relative path to that module
and that's how you reference it in uh
other JavaScript
modules and in some cases your modules
may be uh constru have Constructor
functions it's you know just a common
JavaScript thing so instead of uh
creating a using after you require it in
as a as an object then you might want
might want to create an instance of it
using the Constructor function or it
might say VAR service equals new my
service
and then a very very common pattern in
node.js is to is using callbacks so if
you're calling a method on a JavaScript
function uh a JavaScript object like
service. some method then you're going
to pass in any number of parameters that
are required by that object or by that
method and then you're going to pass in
a callback function and that is this is
this is part of that being uh courteous
of the single-threaded event loop it's
like I'm going to call this function and
you you handle when you're going to
execute that function when you're done
then call back this uh this call back
function that I'm providing as as the
last parameter so the common pattern is
to use uh a call back that starts with
error which is the error object and then
whatever additional results may be being
returned from that uh call back so we
check the error do something if we need
if we have that error
there are a couple of different module
patterns um that are common with
nodejs um the this one is uh just using
plain
Json so we've got a module sample module
1. JS and it's got a couple of functions
in it a convert to Celsius and a convert
to Fahrenheit and then at the end we've
got this this plain this this Json
object literal it's got some properties
like the uh
freezing Celsius and freezing Fahrenheit
boiling and then our we've got our two
functions here's where the magic happens
in the commonjs module framework is
somewhere in your module you need to set
your exports and here we're saying our
exports is this this JavaScript object
so when sample module one is used
somewhere else in nodejs it's going to
see the freezing and boiling uh uh
properties and it's going to see those
two functions and that's all it's that
that's what it that's all it's going to
see another common uh pattern is to uh
use a Constructor function and here
we're we're requiring in the file system
object and then we've got this one
function that takes in uh a parameter
called a a path and inside this function
we're we're going ahead and we're
reading uh the config data from that
file that was provided From the Path and
we're parsing that as Json and then
we've got a number of functions I've you
know the Implement implementation
details are not so important uh but
we've got a get a set a save and then
we've got some you know internal
function and then we're returning from
this Constructor function what we want
to expose to the to the outside world so
we're returning the get and the set and
the save and then we're setting that
Constructor function as our module.
exort so when you use this in some other
area of our node.js application we're
going to create an instance of it using
the require we're going to uh use that
path you know pass in a path and then
the object that we get at the end is a
uh an object that just has get set and
save you know
exposed how many here use SQL server and
you're not so for me node.js for for
many years was um a non-starter I I I
kind of dismissed nodejs because SQL
server was not you know very well
supported uh once SQL server was
supported then I became a Hu you know I
started using node.js more and I became
a huge fan I'm a SQL database nerd I've
been using SQL Server since the you know
the late '90s so uh it's a it's a
important piece of techn technology to
me so seriate is one of the uh several
node.js modules that that's available
for SQL Server uh it's my favorite so I
get asked this a lot uh so I included
some of these slides in my my talk just
to talk a little bit about uh how easy
it is to get started with the SQL Server
so ser8 uh you'll have some kind of
config um setting your your database
connection properties and then you can
do things like uh seriate is based on
finite State machines and and Promises
so you can do some really interesting
things about you know I want to execute
this this uh this SQL code and the
results that I get back from that SQL
statement I want to execute another
sequel statement you know I can chain
SQL statements together in like step one
step two step three and then do
something interesting with the whole
chain of of executions at the end and
then I can wrap it up into you know you
have like a cat statement for any errors
that that
happen and if you want to know more
about uh serate if you go to my my blog
reverent geek.com I've got an article
out there on uh titled uh painless SQL
server with uh node.js using
ser8 so a little information about
deploying uh typically when you deploy a
nodejs application you don't include the
node J node modules folder so this is a
special folder that's created when you
in when you're installing packages so
when I do an mpm install low Dash or mpm
install express it puts everything in
this node modules folder if there are
native modules for you know say I'm I'm
developing on a Mac and those native
modules get compiled I don't want to I
don't want to deploy node modules
because it may be the wrong architecture
or the wrong you know native modules for
for wherever you know I might be
deploying to a Linux machine so so
typically you're going to deploy to the
server and then run mpm install on that
server so that it pulls down all the
packages and compiles them for that
particular server unless you're going to
create uh you have like Ci servers that
are the exact same architecture that you
have in production so we do this where
we have uh build servers that are the
same architecture and they're going to
pull they're going to do the job of
pulling down those mpm packages and uh
building them and then we'll take and
zip all that stuff up and and move it
into
production as I mentioned before Azure
is really really easy uh to to deploy to
and then on Windows if you're deploying
no. JS applications you're you're going
to use something like I IIs node to host
uh you can you know if you're just doing
a web application IIs node allows you to
host a node.js application in
IIs and if you're going to be deploying
Services where you need to start and
stop those services and you know
automatically restart if something fails
uh Windsor is a is a great tool for
doing that so when you're when you're
installing a a a nodejs application on a
Windows machine that's going to live on
its own uh which can be a web
application or it could be a like a
micros service Windsor is a great way to
do that and then on Linux there are a
number of options available we use uh
one called Forever and it does the same
kind of thing where it creates a a Damon
so that you can host that application
and it makes sure that if it crashes
it's going to automatically restart and
all those kinds of
things hosting node.js on Azure you can
do something as simple as create a a
brand new uh web app empty node.js uh
application and then
um point that to a repository this is
what I do for a number of my my personal
node.js projects including my blog is I
can just point uh Azure to a GitHub
repository and then anytime I push an
update to that repository to to the
branch that it's looking for it can be
the master Branch or it can be some
other uh branch on that repository it
will automatically detect that change
and pull down the latest uh from that
repository and redeploy my my Azure
website for me so that within less than
a minute typically
I've got uh that version of my my
node.js application running and if you
want to learn more about that I've also
got a blog post on my website about uh
hosting node.js on on
Azure recommended tools so low Dash is a
is a a great uh set of JavaScript
utilities you're probably already
familiar with low Dash or
underscore uh if you're going to do
JavaScript promises when it there's a
number of them uh when is my favorite
async is kind of like your task parallel
Library your TPL for for uh for node.js
uh it gives you the ability to like
execute many many JavaScript functions
in parallel or in serial so that you you
can say I want I want to do all these 10
things and just let me know when all 10
things are done so I can move on um if
you're going to make external calls to
other apis and rest services uh request
is a great module for that gulp um of
course there's you know lots of debate
on you know what what the best uh build
and test Runner and all those kinds of
things are Gulp or grunt uh both are
both are great uh I prefer gulp uh
socket.io is a great library for doing
that realtime uh socket web socket type
implementations node inspector for
debugging is really awesome uh when you
install node node inspector you can
launch your Java your node.js
applications using node dasd you know
instead of typing node space uh index.js
or whatever your your application uh
starting point is you can do node
ddeb uh app.js or index.js and that will
launch your application with the Chrome
uh Dev tools open so that you can use
Chrome I mean Visual Studio code is
really really good but before Visual
Studio code I was using uh node
inspector to do you know node debugging
on uh on the the client side mocha and
chai and sonon those are great testing
Frameworks uh for doing like a tdd or
bdd style of um of of development and
again uh there's there just seems to be
so much less friction with doing a test
driven development style approach to to
develop I don't know what your
experience has been like but there have
been over the years in my career I've
I've gotten like okay this time you know
we're really going to do test driven
development and you know a net project
starts we're we're doing everything tdd
and at some point the wheels just fall
off you know it just gets so hard to
maintain the test that you end up you
know well we got to ship this we got to
get this out the door we don't have time
to uh fix these all these broken tests
and you just start to comment out test
or disable them and then you just give
up you know it's like you throw your
hands up uh that's not been the case
with the node.js projects that we've
done it's been really really awesome uh
and and so much more U so much less
friction in maintaining those those
tests there are a lot of node.js
Frameworks available for doing
um web apps and API uh we've talked
about Express it's like I said it's if
you're if you pick up a book on node.js
or watch any videos almost all of them
are going to point you to express but
that's not the only option happy is uh a
really awesome framework built by
Walmart U that's what they use for all
their production stuff and it's all open
source uh I've got a couple of good
friends that have worked on Happy um
that used to work for Walmart and have
been contributors to that meteor and
sales if you want to do just strict API
work uh restify is really good loop back
uh which is from strong Loop uh IBM now
owns them uh they have built in like
push notifications for mobile apps as
part of their API um my company has a
bunch of Open Source projects out on
link kit Labs uh one of those being Auto
host and hyped it's a hyper media based
approach to doing apis in uh node.js
and you can find a lot more out on node
framework in node uh webm modules. comom
there's kind of like a a curated list of
lots and lots of of Frameworks that are
available another thing I want to tell
you about is uh this tool called Edge
JS uh Edge JS allows you to run net in
process with node.js and it's not just
about C but you can run FSH ado.net you
can even do Python and Powershell so
this could be a way of bridging uh
existing net code with your node.js
applications it was built by the guy who
uh who uh created IIs node the guy who
worked at Microsoft that that made sure
that uh no. JS could run on Windows in
the first place so this is a really
interesting tool allows you to execute
inline code or you can reference uh like
CS files or even uh existing net
assemblies and it's a great alternative
to writing native modules uh instead of
having to write them in C you could
write them in you know in net or or
leverage some existing net uh uh
libraries that you have it does require
net 4.5 or mono 3.1 and that's because
uh those are when um async and a weight
were introduced because you can't do any
blocking calls on node.js you remember
you've got that single threaded event
Loop uh if you're if you're using
synchronous blocking calls uh in for for
net then you're you're halting the the
the thread that you have so you got to
all your code is got to follow the async
and await pattern uh which may mean that
if you have existing uh net code that
you want to leverage through sjs you
have you might have to wrap those uh
with some async and A8 you know create
like a wrapper Library around that
existing code so that you can use
them so what can you do with Edge JS
well you can as I mentioned you can
leverage some of your net uh investment
you can do things like TF you know sh uh
you can do things like Microsoft
services that don't get a whole lot of
love in the node.js community so there
are a lot of modules that are available
for for Microsoft types things but most
of them are Half Baked and abandoned so
net is still going to be your your best
best uh you know clients for some of
these Microsoft uh
applications uh if you want to do active
directory or you want to uh in some
cases maybe net has a has better
Hardware support for for particular
drivers or uh uh Wind 32 uh
drivers and then uh there there not that
there aren't great modules already for
for node for doing like video coding and
CPU intensive work so those are like
native those are like C libraries that
are that are being compiled for node but
if you've got some very specific things
that you want to be able to do with node
that are CPU intensive then net may be a
great
alternative and then Powershell is is an
interesting uh option for doing some
like automation of of devops type
things some node.js integration
strategies uh node.js is a proxy so this
is a uh how a lot of these organizations
have introduced node into their or into
their um their stack of Technologies uh
Walmart and PayPal these guys have what
they've done is they've created first
created a proxy API which is everything
that that that you can talk to right and
uh it's you know sometimes referred to
as the strangulation pattern where you
have something things are implemented in
node and some things are just handed off
to whatever Legacy backend system that
that you're still having to to use for a
while and then slowly you're migrating
uh those features and functionality to
node.js over time so uh you might use
node.js as a proxy and even using Edge
JS to be able to call into some of those
Legacy if you want to call them legacy.
net applications or services so that you
know as you're starting to re recreate
those things create new ones in in
node.js you can do
that uh if you need to call into other
web API maybe you're using uh you know
asp.net web API for for some of your
things you can use request module to
call into those apis from node and then
uh this is this is what we're using at
at my company is rabbit mq you can use a
message bus is a great way to to to
integrate different systems together so
aure service bus or rabbit mq or some
other type of message queuing technology
you can have messages that are published
onto a message CU and you may have some
services that are built in Donnet and
some Services built in in node they're
all able to read and and send messages
on that
queue and the last thing I want to tell
you is that you don't need permission to
be awesome so I believe us as software
developers we are living in and you know
this is no better time to be a software
developer than than right now we have so
much technology that's available to us
we have the ability to to change our
world um our the companies that we work
for uh the reason you're here is so that
you can learn about new stuff and take
that back to your organization and do uh
do awesome things and I I can I can tell
you my experience with nodejs has been
uh just so much fun it's made me want to
uh excited about being a programmer
again um not you know it's just learning
new things is is is such a a fun thing
to do and I'm so glad that we live in a
in a world and Industry that allows us
to continue to learn and to grow our
skills and so
forth and with that I've got some a lot
of uh demos and and resources out on
this link I've got a number of
repositories uh that have some node.js
things there's a uh
yeah so there's a lot of resources
available from that link um again I'm
I'm Reverend geek on on the Twitter's uh
that's probably I'm a Twitter addict so
that's probably the best way to get a
hold of me and we got just maybe four
minutes left for some questions anybody
got a
question yes sir so um when I'm trying
to use no especially when I'm trying to
upm or whatever and I have Studio
install sometimes I think it was still
using the
old so the questions about upgrading
node on uh and and having running into
some issues with with mpm stick sticking
around um I ran into some problems with
that early on earlier versions of node I
think uh especially if you're Tred to
upgrade mpm manually over
um um yeah it's a a good question I
don't think I've run into that in in
recent builds of of node.js I think
they've fixed some of those problems on
on Windows but um but definitely the
latest version of node.js tools for for
visual studio does require you to have
the latest like update three and and
those you know so there's there's a
number of dependencies that may I'll be
coming into play there that that could
be messing things
up
yesl do you use
any uh so the question is do you use an
OM with with SQL um I do not uh seriate
is kind of like as as far as a an omm
it's kind of like you might consider a
micro orm uh it's got some just some
very very lightweight capabilities um
JavaScript being a Dynamic language
already gives you like instant mapping
of of information that's coming from the
database so there's you're not having to
go through a bunch of Hoops to turn the
data into some object model or something
like that uh because Json is just the
nature of it is just so much less work
to do that kind of thing so it um I I
think there are some ORS that are
available but uh personally I I don't I
don't know of any in or can recommend
any to you how to
result way
toon yes so as soon as you get um you
know your results back from from the uh
from SQL they are it's Auto
automatically a Json object that you can
then take and it's you know um all the
properties and and things are there so
there's no additional work that has to
be done to translate the results set
into uh it's already in
JavaScript objects yes
siring without having a compiler do you
so refactoring code without a compiler
um so having lots of tests is a is a
great way is you know it's kind of like
a discipline to have to to catch
anything that that that might happen um
we there's there's things like es lent
and jscs so eslint has got some really
powerful capabilities to to let you know
that hey you're you're using things
wrong or or this object no longer exists
in your code or you know can give you
you know some hints on that um but
mostly I find it's through through you
know having really good tests that that
can find those things I know some people
use typescript and that's that's their
way of of making sure that things are
are lining up correctly um but um yeah
es6 es 2015 and all the other features
with es lent I think provide a really
good safety net as well
yes so the the questions about um
proxies and authentication through
through those proxies from node yeah
um I don't have a good answer for that
uh I know we have used like the request
object and it has some basic proxy
authentication things and I know we
we've contributed ourselves to like uh
the MS SQL package for doing like ntl
ntlm
authentication um but I yeah I don't I
don't know
um yeah I can I can help help you try to
track some things down afterwards that
sure well
we we are out of time H I will be here
for for a while longer you can certainly
come up to me and ask questions uh
follow me on Twitter uh thank you guys
very
much